In this app, we see an example,
of a defragmented network traffic
that uses the big cookie model.
All the repeating transfers
have been bundled together,
and all the intermittent transfers
have been largely replaced
with aggressive prefetching.
Obviously, you usually can't entirely
predict what data users might need.
Nor can you ignore either client
or service site changes
that need to be synchronized.
You can aim to minimize the number
of radio state transitions
through a combination
of aggressive prefetching
in addition to batching and queueing
any transfers that aren't time critical
and bundling these with
user initiated time critical transfers,
or those initiated from the server.
If we compare the impact
on the radio of the big cookie model
compared to the previous
on demand approach,
you can see it's now idle
nearly two thirds of the time.
Even the active radio percentage
has significantly dropped,
thanks to improved download efficiency
as a result of transmitting
more data in one shot.